[Music]
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
oh here we go
[Applause]
hey baby
hey baby
[Music]
it's going to be for you
you keep it
there's more where that came from too
trust me
that's my girl oh damn i'm straight up
talking about some daryl donkeys right
here because this is some chocolate
thunder what girl make it rain
yeah
oh yeah i try to make it laughs
all right girl um
i'm gonna get it right in the booty
right there uh and do this well that's
what you call a booty investment
it's a plan brother you really don't
need to uh uh give them that much i
don't think they're expecting all that
it's kind of like feeding a squirrel you
know i mean they will come back to you
so oh oh oh my gosh some of this is
getting lost let's get it right where it
need to be right in there baby oh yeah
keep it classy
keep it classy oh somebody better get an
umbrella because i can't stop making the
rain it's like it's like no it's flooded
up in here
two by two baby two by two
maybe you don't know that i'm the
general because it's storm in norman
that's what they be calling me
[Music]
damn
anyway like i said
when you finish training we get scotty
mutsy up in here
that you can train a box
[Music]
oh lord have mercy you don't know about
this
make it rain
are you an idiot
leon get this guy out of here all right
nobody move
there he is there who is you on your
feet
on your feet
what i do you're under arrest for
photocopying money oh god damn it
you know how long it took me to cut all
that out got carpal tunnel syndrome up
in this [ __ ]
callus is on the inside of my thumbs
that's definitely real though
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party till the
party don't stop and the party don't
stop because it keeps on going non-stop
gonna party all night gonna keep this
party going cause the party won't stop
it's been two straight days and the
party's still going two three four five
six seven days till it's friday again
and the party keeps going party all
night cause it's an all night party
friday night 9 p.m hop in the car call
my friends drinks in the back girls up
front going to a party sending texts
cell phone rings ipad facebook party
time skin tight jeans friday nights
dance dance cause tonight we're going
out and we ain't coming back cause the
party won't stop it we'll go all night
friday night every night the party's
going down now girl no no no
[Music]
the party won't stop and we'll go all
night friday night every night the
party's going down down down down
new york city l.a chicago houston philly
san diego phoenix austin fort worth
boston memphis denver portland vegas
tucson fresno akron tampa pittsburgh
plano lincoln loving durham salem
[Music]
party
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
party don't stop
all right
that's right sergeant crandall united
states i'm a recruiter how y'all doing
this is my associates sergeant graham
pax
nice feet gentlemen we want to talk to
you about your future and where you fit
in the united states army y'all yeah in
case you haven't heard we're asking and
you're telling that's right no
restrictions man you won't be surrounded
by dudes all day y'all get exercise
together you can shower together talking
about soap water the worst now i know
what you're thinking the arm is
dangerous but the fact of the matter is
everything's dangerous all depends on
what's your definition of the word
danger is oh yeah what
all right
oh here we go we got my friend
all right
hey we already got him
but you're better off in the army
because we're gonna get you in the best
shape in your whole life
[Music]
there's a bunch of men in a tight space
with flashing lights and loud noises
just like this
yeah you're right
[Music]
all
right
excuse me there young man have you ever
thought about joining the united states
army just oh oh excuse me i will uh talk
to you too late to part of me
can you totally chillax i'm so annoyed
right now can you like not talk to me
for like a second like that'd be great
that'd be fine that'd be fine by me
but oh my god are you serious this is
bull
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
check your girl bro
excuse me what did you say check your
girl uh-uh it doesn't work like that no
one checks me because i'm not luggage
okay so you can go
yourself
megan seriously two more people are
gonna come out in a couple of seconds
and then we can go in yeah
let me ask you a question what was it
like being in the green mile he wasn't
in the green mile and clearly wasn't in
that movie what does tom hanks's penis
feel like meegan moreover how does it
feel when swarms of bees are coming out
of your face seriously i'm sorry it's
like a favorite movie don't apologize
for me yeah this is nice this is nice
you look like common meets the
incredible hulk
when you brought the frankincense to
baby jesus did they like make you stand
outside the barn because you were too
big or did they invite you in with all
the other animals don't flare your nose
without me okay do you have any idea how
impolite that is he hasn't moved his
nostrils
once since we got here i saw the move
they did not move me again they flare
megan they [ __ ] did not move your
nostrils flared more than a survivor
from a boat accident
what he's not even looking in the eyes
okay you know what if you're just gonna
continue to be a little prick you're
gonna get your ass kicked don't touch
your me meegan
crazy [ __ ]
totally love my nails right now
so over everything right now over the
floor i'm over the sky i'm over you over
that [ __ ] back there you're a [ __ ]
naked seriously whatever
um
excuse me oh god hey
what did you say what the [ __ ]
did you just say
you guys come back here with your little
itty bitty
dicks
you best control your lady yup
excuse
control your lady no he doesn't control
me cause let me tell you something
i'm not a remote megan baby can we just
let this go no i'm talking to the
[ __ ] of anarchy right now yeah you
why don't you all gather yourselves and
why don't you just go and figure out a
way to on each other's leathery penis
hey you
[Music]
[ __ ] ah
it's not even the plural of penis
yeah
i'm the queen of the world
yes
i feel invincible like i have
superpowers or something
you hear that all you ask in the world i
can do anything i want and no one can
stop me guess you don't have to fight
your own fights a crazy [ __ ]
oh boy
nothing can stop me
[Music]
it's friday night make some
if you cool noise a pimp put your hands
up if you cool like a pimp put your
hands up cause you're an actual pimp put
your hands up if you own a bunch of
women put your hands up
[Music]
for 12 hours put your hands up
without the benefit of viagra put your
hands up
[Music]
if you a real live player put your hands
up if you abuse women's trust put your
hands up if you treat her like objects
put your hands up
[Music]
if you a real-life gangster put your
hands up if you a real-life gangster put
your hands up if you kill other people
put your hands up
[Music]
if you're the biggest boss here put your
hands up
if you run an actual drug ring put your
hands up
if you just realize that you're full of
[ __ ] put your hands up
[Music]